- [Voiceover] Let's see if we can evaluate
the indefinite integral of tangent x dx.
Like always, pause the video and see
if you can figure it out on your own
and I will give you a hint,
think reverse chain rule.
Alright, so you have attempted it
and you would say well reverse chain rule,
that's kind of your seeing a function
and your seeing it's derivative
and you can integrate with
respect to that function.
All you see here is a tangent
of x, what am I talking about?
Well, whenever you see a tangent of x
or a cosecant or a secant,
at least in my brain,
I always like to break it
down into how it's defined
in terms of sine and cosine because we do
at least have some tools at our disposal
for dealing with sines and cosines.
Or at least our brains, at least my brain,
has an easier time processing them.
We know tangent of x is
the same thing as sine of x
over cosine of x so let
me rewrite it that way.
This is equal to the indefinite
integral of sine of x
over cosine of x dx and you
could even write it this way
and this is a little bit of a hint.
You could even write it as sine of x
times one over cosine of x.
If you couldn't figure
it out the first time,
I encourage you to pause the video again
and, once again, think reverse chain rule.
So, what am I talking about when
I keep saying reverse chain rule?
Let's just review that before
I proceed with this example.
If I were to just tell you, well what's
the indefinite integral of one over x dx?
We know that, that's going to be
the natural log of the
absolute value of x plus c.
Now, if I were to ask you what is
the indefinite integral of f prime
of x times one over f of x dx.
What is that going to be?
Here's where the reverse
chain rule applies.
Where I have one over f of x,
if only I had it's derivative
being multiplied by this
thing then I could just
integrate with respect to f of x.
Well, I do, I have it's
derivative right over here.
It's multiplying times this thing.
I can use the reverse chain rule to say
that this is going to be equal
to the natural log of the absolute value
of the thing that I
have in the denominator,
which is f of x plus c
and that is exactly...
I've made it too wide so
you can't see everything...
but that's exactly what's
going on right over here.
I have, if I say this
thing right over here,
cosine of x is f of x,
then sine of x is not quite
the derivative, it's the
negative of the derivative.
F prime of x would be negative sine of x.
How do I get that, how do I engineer it?
What if I just threw a negative there
and a negative there so it is essentially
multiplying by negative one twice
which is still going to stay positive.
Negative sine of x, right over here,
I'm trying to squeeze it in
between the integral sine
and the sine of x, this right over here,
now that I put a negative sine of x,
that is the derivative of cosine of x.
This is f prime of x so I can just
apply the reverse chain rule.
This is going to be, we deserve
a little mini drum roll
here, this is going
to be equal to the natural
log of the absolute value
of our f of x, which is
going to be cosine of x.
Then, of course, we have our plus c
and we can't forget we
had this little negative
sitting out here so we're going
to have to put the
negative right over there.
And we are done, we just figured out
that's kind of a neat result because
it feels like that's something we
should know how to take
the indefinite integral of.
The indefinite integral
of tangent of x is,
and it's neat they're connected
in this way, is the negative
natural log of the absolute
value of cosine of x plus c.